trivia question for the sunday surprise
draft how about this
tua tungawa the first rookie quarterback
to beat bill belichick and the patriots
since who chris i heard this yesterday
gino smith of the jets
i heard somebody say it on on a
highlight show or somewhere during a
game yesterday i might have heard it at
the end of that football game and then
of course our producer is a jets fan so
of course he knows that and that's what
he asks i mean just too too predictable
too
too predictable i mean it could have
been mark sanchez could have mark
sanchez
uh you're right it could have been
you're right um
how do i not start there you know with a
jets fan asking a question that centers
around the jets
how can we not start with the sunday
surprise being the winless jets
go to la to play the los angeles rams
who i don't know i mean we've at least
had the conversation a few times over
the last five six weeks where we go
i don't know the rams the best team in
the nfc i don't know i mean the nfc is
hard to figure out
but either way you know that was the
sunday shocker for me
sam darnold played good football jets
ran the ball a little bit
their defense really was the story of
the day they never let
mcveigh and goff really get in a rhythm
uh
in any way you know quinn and williams
before he got hurt him and nathan
shepard upfront the defensive tackles
they were whooping butt
and slowing down that rams running game
so that that to me was amazing
you know the fact that the the jets you
know really you could sit there and go
they won
almost all three phases of the game they
might have won all three phases of the
game and pulled off an upset against the
playoff caliber team as uh
shocker yeah 17 point underdogs and
won the game straight up and you and i
both had rams as our best bets we were
0 2 and 1 combined in best bets
this week and we got pushes on the two
games
on the one game that we disagreed on we
had two that were the same that we both
lost
we had different ones for our third one
and we got pushes independently you had
seattle
given five to washington push i had
kansas city
given three to the saints push so uh not
a great week for us but even worse
for the rams at least at least we can
move on the rams have to live with this
one for a little bit
first one for me to go back to the top
story of the day
the fact that brees played when he
clearly
wasn't ready to play how was that not a
surprise
i wouldn't have expected him back on the
field until he was
100 or close to it just last monday
night
on espn at halftime of the game
chef he's in he's not they're not going
to put him back on the field until he's
100 or close to it well
he's not close to 100 and i'm amazed
that somehow someway
there was a misfire in an otherwise
buttoned up from top to bottom saints
organization which
always finds a way to make the right
decision do the right thing
move in the right direction to let drew
brees play yesterday when he
should not have been playing was a
stunner
to me just a half click below the fact
that the jets found a way to win a game
no uh i mean i'm with you this
just the way brees looked all together
was you know surprising for sunday it
really was it was shaky
like we talked about to start the show
he never looked comfortable in the
pocket
or what he was seeing down the field uh
it was really
off yesterday there's no doubt um i'm
surprised too that it looked that way
or that it was that far away from being
a hundred percent
um but either way yeah it cost them
yesterday it did that game they had a
chance to question
if the offense was a little better but
do you think peyton
considered getting him out of there i i
i in that moment i don't think you can
no i don't think so i don't think you
can do it even if you think about it i
don't think you can do it no i think
that opens up more more can of worms
than they want to deal with and then you
got to talk about that and then oh who's
going to start this week is going to be
taysom hill or drew brees
you know again in a year where not
having the number one seed is
is is you know not a huge deal because
no crowd and all of that
um hey we're gonna have to looking like
we're going to have to see drew brees on
the road most likely
in lambeau inland atlanta would be a
good chance right which
you know the way he threw the ball
yesterday and everything like that that
scares you when you think about that and
you go well that was a perfect
environment
he goes to lambeau it's not going to be
perfect the ball is going to be slick
and frozen and there's going to be wind
and what's it going to look like if you
throw some of those passes we saw
yesterday
you know in late january so uh
hey hopefully they can get him in a
groove here these last two weeks to
where he can get to the playoffs and you
know kind of be hitting on
on all systems go um
i'm gonna go this is more of a big
picture thing but we haven't hit on this
game and i just i mean
the the titans they're offense it's just
it's not even just a surprise for
yesterday it's a surprise for the whole
year because what the titans are one of
those things mike and i know i said this
to you like off air
that we hadn't hit the game and it's
just one of those you look at the stats
sometimes hey let me see where this off
you know and you go whoa wait the titans
are the number two offense in football
i just i don't know if a lot of people
really realize that and how explosive
they are on that side of the football
and what they did yesterday the lions
you know they're just their ability to
make big plays in the run game and pass
game
it's up there with anybody it might not
be as cool and as fun and highlighty
and you know fantasy football driven
maybe as the kansas city chiefs and all
that but it's
every bit as effective as the kansas
city chiefs
in a lot of ways i mean they can do it
whatever way they want
it's yeah we can run the ball and break
off big plays but when we get to drop
back and throw the ball
make big plays there they're one of the
best there is at that as well
it's just uh remarkable what they've
done and that's a guy like arthur smith
the offensive coordinator for the titans
you don't hear his name a whole lot
he probably needs to be you know talked
about that head coach top offensive
coordinator conversation
a little bit more put a pin in that
comment because that
is one of my centerpiece grievances
coming up on
the actual day of festivus the black
holiday created by
frank costanza wednesday december 23.
but uh two quick points about that great
performance we saw yesterday from the
titans
the final score 46.25 that was
the first time there's ever been a score
of 46-25 in 101 years of nfl football
which is amazing that's a
scorigami as they call it online and
there were two this weekend 48-19 the
bills win over the broncos
another one we got two of them in one
week uh
1050 unique scores now
of nfl games in 101 seasons all right
next one for me
sullivan ahmed the dolphins running back
who had played in three games before
uh sunday and was pressed into service
because miles gaskin
was injured ahmed's grandmother's in the
hospital
he told her he'd get 100 yards and he
did he got 122 on 23 carries and a
touchdown that he is taking the ball
to her he told me she's doing better uh
which is which is
obviously good news but a neat little
story and a surprise a definite surprise
i doubt that he was on many fantasy
lineups in yesterday's
fantasy playoffs chris no definitely not
but you know that that
just it speaks to the bigger picture of
what the dolphins are doing down there
you know how well they've built their
football team the fact that they can
find a free agent talent like that
you know and the fact that if they can
play defense
and the way they've been playing and run
the ball just even somewhat close to the
way they ran the ball yesterday
you know that bodes well for them being
a pain in the butt in the playoffs if
they can get in
because two is not at the point right
yet where he's going to carry the team
and drop back pass and throw lasers all
over the field no they're still managing
him
he's making some plays here and there
but that's the way
that's the fact of where they are right
now so they need that run game to help
some of those boots and play actions
that they want to do with tua
and make them a more effective and that
could be an effective formula as far as
uh
playoffs are concerned all right my next
one
i mean i don't know i'm not shocked but
i'm still
shocked okay the the falcons
the the the brady comeback the ownership
of brady
over the atlanta falcons that still was
amazing i just
you know again we know the falcons
aren't good but up 17 to nothing against
hey it's tom brady his first year in
tampa
man i don't know and the way atlanta was
looking i just thought
i don't know if this is gonna be one of
those days brady can bring them back
that was amazing and the the way in
which he did it how quickly they made
plays to bring them back
and just how good brady looked doing it
that was a sunday surprise for me
they start putting full games together
and they are going to the super bowl and
it's going to be brady and
and mahomes together in tampa for super
bowl
55. last one for me um
tony pollard and the cowboys uh paula
had 130 plus yards from scrimmage and
the cowboys get the win on the day when
everyone else in the division loses and
i had made the joke saturday night when
the rose bowl announced
that the game will be played at a t
stadium
and it may not even be called the rose
bowl and i said hey they're finally
going to have a meaningful playoff game
in dallas this year
but they're they could still win that
division they're not dead yet
wouldn't it be amazing if the cowboys
find a way to get hot i'm stunned that
they beat the 49ers as are you that was
another one of our best bets that blew
up in our faces
and uh good for the cowboy thanks nick
mullins thanks nick
yeah yeah thanks stefan georgiovich very
good
the game has got no competitive meaning
but when the game gets real again
man he's a disaster well he got he
finally got yanked yesterday for cj
beathard we'll see what they do
next week against the arizona cardinals
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports